le tour du monde en chanson c'est le
thème de la comédie musicale des
résidents des Réau à hencour des danses
thtiennes des décor japonais et des
chansons allemandes sont au programme de
la représentation un spectacle créé et
interprété par les personnes en
situation de handicap du foyer
médicalisé àencour au total 18 mois de
répétition pour une seule
représentation stressé parce que je
recommence et devant les gens je suis
pas habitué ce que je dois penser qu'il
y a personne dans la salle
parce que si je pense qu'il y a des gens
je vais me bourrer je
vais bourrer pas bon Michel éta un peu
triste on a tous
promis les 12 personnes sur scène
revisitent des chansons bien connues
comme les Beatles et des musiques
bretonnes les résidents jouent leur
propre rôle durant leur propre tour du
monde c'est la trè fois que les
organise un spectacle il s'est déroulé à
l'espace Albert Camu de
morpa